we now come to the leader of the
opposition care Starbucks
Mr Speaker
can I join the prime minister in paying
tribute to the brave British Personnel
involved in the evacuation effort from
Sudan
government must do everything in its
power to urgently evacuate UK Nationals
still trapped in Sudan
Mr Speaker yesterday George Osborne said
that the Tory party's handling of the
economy makes them Vandals
he's right isn't he
[Applause]
yes
the business of quoting former
chancellors and Shadow chancellors I
don't know if he saw the remarks from a
former labor Shadow Chancellor yesterday
who said our country had faced four Once
in a century shocks threats to our
economy and the fact that we've come
through it is a Triumph Mr Speaker
well that former Chancellor not only
said there were a bunch of Tory vandals
he also said there was a self-induced
financial crisis on the country that's
those vandals and they like to pretend
that it was all just one week of Madness
last Autumn but the truth is it's been
13 years of failure
real wages the money in people's pockets
have fallen by sixteen hundred pounds
per household sixteen hundred pounds the
prime minister's response to impose 24
Tory tax rises in three years 24. how on
Earth does he think his low growth
high-tax economy is working for working
people
[Applause]
taken on the national living wage at
record levels on pension on Universal
Credit and the generous cost of living
payments just yesterday Mr Speaker
almost 8 million households receiving
direct support from this cost of this
conservative government we are
supporting working people but just this
week Mr Speaker in The Other Place we've
seen his party side with protesters and
with picketers he should actually try
backing working people
[Applause]
thank you
he lost sixteen hundred pounds worse off
Mr Speaker I'm genuinely fascinated to
know does he really think that
everything's fine or is he just clueless
about life outside of his bubble
[Applause]
Mr Speaker because because of the
actions that we have taken well let's
just go over it a single mother a single
mother working full-time on the national
living wage this year will get 1 300
pounds more support from this government
a working couple on low income with two
children will get 1 800 pounds Mr
Speaker that's what delivering for
working Britain looks like but if he has
any actual ideas for the economy he
should say so because all I hear from
the party opposite it's more spending
more borrowing higher inflation higher
interest rates it's the same old labor
party
[Applause]
this is Mr 24 tax Rises
never heard anything so
far that he is
just his refusal to take any
responsibility for the damage they've
done the crashed economy the hits of
living standards it's also he refuses to
take the action that's needed he could
stop the handouts he's giving to oil and
gas giants he could scrap his beloved
non-dom status
he could put that money back in the
hands of working people and get the NHS
back on his feet that's what a labor
government would do
why doesn't he
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the record was clear look at
it right now record record numbers of
people in work Mr Speaker record numbers
of people in work inequality no lower
the number of people in poverty lower
those in low pay the lowest numbers on
record Mr Speaker he talks about this
London thing I think he's already spent
the money that he claims he's raised on
five different things Mr Speaker because
it's the same old labor party they're
always running out of other people's
money
[Applause]
I don't know if last week I'm certainly
not having this continuous noise so just
be aware that somebody will be going for
that cup of tea today prime minister Mr
Speaker he calls it this non-dom thing
let's let's be honest about what his
refusal to scrap the non-dom status
means it means that at every possible
opportunity he has voted to put taxes up
on working people while at the same time
taking every possible opportunity to
protect a tax avoidance scheme that
helped his own finances
why is the prime minister telling people
across the country that their taxes must
go up so that his can stay low
[Applause]
to these the very wealthiest pay more
tax and the poorest pay less tax under
that today than an under any year of the
last Labor government Mr Speaker we've
also boosted the national living wage
boosted Universal Credit and pensioners
but Mr Speaker the rank hypocrisy of it
as we saw as we saw last week when it
comes to his own special pension scheme
I mean and I I said I said it last week
but I'll say again it's it's literally
one law for him and a tax rise for
everybody else
Mr Speaker
here's the difference odd scrap his
pension giveaway whether it affected me
or not
he refuses he refuses to scrap the
non-dom status that benefits him and his
family because I can see why he's
attracted to this non-dom thing
this prime minister is so removed from
the country that he boasted that he
didn't know a single working-class
person
so insulated from reality that he
proudly told a Tory Garden Party how
he'd move money from poorer areas and
handed it to rich ones
so out of touch that he looks at a
petrol pump and a debit card like
they've just arrived from Mars
Smiles is
living crisis while putting other
people's taxes up is there any wonder he
doesn't have a clue how food prices a
hammering families across the country
and is it any wonder that under him
people are paying more and more are
getting less and less
Mr Mr
Mr what's happened just in this just in
this week
Mika where the labor party have put
themselves on Monday in the other place
they decided to side with extremist
protesters just yesterday they sided
with polluters Mr Speaker
and tonight and tonight and tonight
and tonight and tonight we will see them
siding with the people Smugglers Mr
Speaker I tell you this whilst we're in
the business of sending back the 1 000
illegal migrant from Albania Mr Speaker
we're delivering cost of living payments
to millions of households just yesterday
and today we've announced we put 20 000
more police officers on the street I
think
we're siding with the British people Mr
Speaker that's what the conservative
government does